pas une fête très très bien c'est la
nouvelle venue carolyn maloney joue à
fond la carte du vent de fraîcheur d'une
vision de nouvelles pour un parti en
crise elle ne cache pas son manque
d'expérience en politique et elle s'en
sert pour se distancer des échecs
conservateur des dernières années en
ontario
c'est quelqu'un qui se dit voyons
nouveau mais c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui est prêt bien enraciné dans l'élite
comtoise et l'élite à la fois économique
et politique en ontario mais au canada
car les deux monnaies a grandi au 24
sussex la résidence du premier ministre
canadien à ottawa
elle n'avait que 19 ans quand son père
brian mulroney a quitté ses fonctions et
s'est ensuite consacrée aux droits
qu'elle a fait ses études aux états unis
elle a commencé à pratiquer en trois à
new york aux états unis donc lien
vraiment du secteur corporatif de retour
chez nous car les deux monnaies a fondé
le chou backs project un organisme qui
vient en aide aux femmes sans abri
puis elle a été vice-présidente d'une
firme de conseillers en investissement
de bay street
elle a aussi été membre du comité pour
la construction d'un nouveau pont entre
windsor et détroit
une initiative du gouvernement harper
était aussi à ses proches certains
secteurs du gouvernement de monsieur
harper c'est en effet son amitié avec
les griefs qui était ministre à l'époque
elle a pu avoir cette poste sur la
commission qui pâtissait un nouveau pont
browser
carolyn maloney met de l'avant son image
de mère de famille de femmes
rassembleuse qui fait son entrée dans un
parti troublé mais son nom et les portes
qu'il a ouverte au fil des années
explique en grande partie sa popularité
c'est de fait qu'elle a le nom moroni
puis toutes les réseaux qu'elle a pu
bâtir à la fraude grâce à ce nom là mais
aussi par son implication à bay street
qui lui donne cette crédibilité comme
candidate
les membres du parti conservateur
devront déterminer si cette crédibilité
suffit à trois mois des élections ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto